Краплинка, з якої утворять печінку.
Орган із пробірки.
Луц Клоке має амбітну мету:
разом з однодумцями він прагне
виробляти штучні органи
і таким чином докорінно змінити
ринок трансплантації.
На такі органи, як нирки чи печінка,
величезний попит.
Донорів обмаль. Що має змінитися?
Те, що пацієнт отримає свій
індивідуальний трансплантат.
Він приходить до лікаря чи в клініку.
У нього беруть клітини,
які розмножують в лабораторії.
Власні клітини і є тим скелетом,
на якому будують новий орган.
Цей власноруч сконструйований
3D-принтер має це уможливити.
До клітин додають біо-інк, своєрідний клей.
Це одна з перший німецьких лабораторій,
якій вдалося надрукувати
живу тканину людських органів.
Наше найбільше досягнення полягає в тому,
що ми удосконалили технологію до такого рівня,
що ми вперше можемо друкувати
фізіологічні моделі,
які імітують функцію людських органів.
Ця печінка ще на початковій стадії.
Так звана долька, тканина печінки.
Ця долька має усі функції печінки,
і я можу тестувати на ній субстанції
і робити висновки,
як реагуватиме справжня печінка в реальності.
Зрозуміло, що ці маленькі моделі, які ми друкуємо,
цікаві і мають важливе застосування.
Але на майбутнє ми хочемо, звісно,
створювати щось, що рятуватиме життя.
Це нас надихає.
Мрійниками називає цей стартап Райнер Крістін.
Він інвестує чимало грошей в медичні технології
і добре знає Cellbricks.
Чоловік цікавиться багатьма стартапами,
однак гроші у друк органів не інвестуватиме.
Мені здається, що це поки далеке майбутнє.
Потенціал, який вбачають у цій технології, цікавий.
Але проект ще не в тому стані,
щоб бути цікавим інвесторам.
Це поки базові дослідження.
Йдеться не про те,
щоб повторити зовнішню форму органів,
адже всередині органи -
це надзвичайно складні механізми.
З огляду на це, досягти того,
щоб справді друкувати органи - справжній виклик.
Поки що не вдалося надрукувати готовий орган.
Але штучні ракові пухлини вже продають клінікам.
Анетте Кюнкеле – педіатр.
Завдяки стартапу Cellbricks
вона змогла просунутись у дослідженні раку.
Ми разом розробляємо 3D-модель пухлини,
яку ми можемо використовувати для досліджень,
вивчати, які імунні клітини
здатні проникати в цю 3D-структуру.
Базуючись на знаннях, які ми здобудемо
завдяки моделі Cellbricks,
вирішуватимемо, які імунні клітини
ми використовуватимемо в лікарнях,
щоб лікувати пацієнтів.
Поки що стартап не переріс у великий бізнес.
Жодних мільйонних інвестицій.
Засновника Cellbricks це не засмучує.
Зрештою, ідеться про велику ідею.
Колись ми хочемо надрукувати
серце, що битиметься.
І саме це нас надихає, а не те,
що колись ми можемо шалено збагатіти.
Робота тут така важка, що люди,
які женуться за грошима, цього не витримають.
Відверто кажучи.